a memorial service will be held today
for one of the five people murdered in
last week's rampage at the Capitol
Gazette newspaper office in Maryland 59
year-old Rob hyacinth assistant managing
editor and columnist only on CBS this
morning chip Reed spoke to a fellow
staffer who narrowly escaped the gunman
he's in Annapolis Maryland chip good
morning
well good morning Paul Gillespie has
been a photojournalist at the Capitol
Gazette here in Annapolis for almost 18
years and he takes pride in being called
the Capitol photographer he says
journalism is in his blood and that's
why he felt compelled to tell his story
I was you know saying I can't believe
this is happening I can't believe I'm
gonna die here you thought you were
gonna die I thought I was gonna die what
kept Paul Gillespie alive was quick
decision making at the start of the
attack I heard a loud pop and then I
heard the glass smash I stood up and
turned around as soon as I saw him I
drove under a desk and then I heard you
know another heard another gunshot after
firing through the Capitol Gazette's
front entrance at about 2:30 the gunman
stormed into the newsroom with 11 people
inside sales assistant Rebecca Smith was
shot first
Gillespie curled under a desk in the
middle of the office as the shooter
began aiming at more of his colleagues
when he sat on just the other side of
the desk that I was under and I heard
her get up and she might have said some
other stuff but the thing I remember
most was her saying no like she was like
she was she was gonna she I think she
was defending herself and then I heard
the shot the gunman shot and killed four
more of Gillespie's co-workers including
Wendy Winters before the rampage the
shooter blocked the offices secondary
entrance leaving only the front entrance
for people like Gillespie to escape I
was making a break for it and whatever
happened happened if I got shot it was
gonna be a bummer but you know I was
gonna at least take you know my chances
go has to be made it outside the
building and ran to a neighboring Bank
for help after catching his breath he
called his wife and I said Janet's me
he's Paul I'm okay somebody came into
the Capitol office in a
and started shooting people and it's
real bad and I can't talk long but it's
bad to help cope with the tragedy
Gillespie is planning to get back to
work all while keeping his colleagues in
mind five people we lost they want us to
go on and make the best of our lives
that we have left
during our interview Gillespie wore a
t-shirt that says journalism matters he
says it was his way of showing support
for all Luke local newspapers all across
the country
he says the Capitol Gazette will move
out of its offices in the building
behind me where this tragedy occurred
and into new offices soon and in the
meantime they're getting plenty of
support and help from the parent company
the Baltimore Sun Gail thank you very
much mr. Gillespie really painted quite
a picture that had to be terrifying or
and you were there I've seen talking
terrifying I remember this a really
tight-knit community too and so that
whole community is mourning the loss and
the Titan of staff there to go through
that with your friends your cohort in
you on